would it be a dream come true to have
Michael J Fox come up and jam with me
that's my dream
[Applause]
[Music]
celebration sit fill this tonight
especially to be not another further
funding drive or not you know kind of
heavy research is a light night it's a
celebration of people that have
supported us in the year that we've had
and me be your head and it's just a
great night every year on this night we
get the privilege of sharing a new
chapter in the story of research
breakthroughs made possible by your
support it's impossible to put into
words but I will do it what it means to
us to know that we count on your
generosity your advice and counsel and
your unflagging belief in what we're
doing
back when the foundation was a
determined underdog we questioned
everything how would we give patients a
seat at the table what role could a
non-profit play in driving serious
results now with your help we're
approaching our 20th year the world sees
this through as a powerhouse and driving
research helping people live well with
the disease educating our community and
advocating for patients and families but
we still see ourselves a serial
disrupter of searching for answers since
we began Parkinson's research has been
transformed several times over and it
will keep doing that thanks to the
science you make possible so the most
important question will remain what will
it take to eradicate this disease once
and for all because whatever it takes
we'll keep bringing